hello everyone and welcome back to
rotten tomatoes is wrong we are almost
at the end of the year but not before we
have another very special guest on this
episode two special guests as a matter
of fact because while my esteemed
co-host jacqueline coley is super busy
when she's not jet setting across the
world she's probably covering an award
show like i believe the golden globes
are right around the corner is that
right the golden globes are right around
the corner so you know jacqueline is
gonna be on hand as i'm fond of saying
she's been to more award shows than dom
perignon she's the best in the biz so
while she's covering that we have i i'm
such a fan of her we've gotten to work
together at festivals at events here at
rotten tomatoes you know her from her
own creation pay or weight that's how
you find her on social media the one the
only representing all of georgia
sharonda williams is back with us hello
sharonda and a pleasant day to you hello
i'm so happy to be here
happy to be in your presence mark i mean
look it's been too long it's been just
about a pandemic since we last saw each
other but we're here on a worthy cause
because we have our very special guest
jay ellis who's gonna be talking uh
about man on fire with us now you all
know jay from insecure it's about to
wrap up their entire series run which
has just been
start to finish a marvelous endeavor
from co-creators issa rae and larry
whitmore jay ellis obviously plays
lawrence and we'll talk about the many
arcs of his character the many ups and
downs of that relationship we're also
going to talk about man on fire sharonda
because it's 38
rotten on the tomato meter and i had to
like i did one of those cartoon like
wipe my eyes make sure i'm looking at
the right score this is such a
celebrated beloved action movie directed
by tony scott starring denzel washington
its audience score is 89 fresh which
sounds accurate 38
on the tomato meter it feels like a
crime and i feel like we're both on the
same page but before we go any further
into our feelings on man on fire i now
have the distinct honor of setting you
up to give us the synopsis of man on
fire sharonda have at it all right so
man on fire okay man on fire aka lesson
in bad parenting
this movie takes place in mexico city
where we find denzel's character we're
going to call him crazy he's a pharmacy
ia operative who is just i mean you can
tell that he's a bad man he's done very
bad things that we don't speak of but we
just know that we should be scared of
him
and essentially he comes into contact
with a young girl who is played by
dakota fanning who literally ate every
scene up that she was in in this movie
and they form a friendship that quickly
gets turned upside down when her
character gets kidnapped and presumably
killed
spoiler alert but you guys should have
already watched this i know right
and essentially we then go on this very
brutal journey of torturing killing in
many creative i shall say very creative
ways as creasy seeks vengeance on
everyone who
had had who has had something to do with
her disappearance due to her raggedy
trash dad who was played by mark anthony
so yeah that's man on fire and i'm glad
you you warned everybody obviously we're
gonna be getting deep into the spoilers
of man on fire so if you haven't seen it
you might want to check it out come on
back or just listen to us gosh about it
and then you can go watch man on fire
and see why
we i think both of us feel the same way
about this movie shirana then we'll get
jay's thoughts on it too directed by
tony scott who obviously did top gun and
i think jay ellis might have something
to do with he's probably seen that movie
i'm willing to bet so
research you know for another film yeah
maybe for another movie he had to watch
the for anyway we'll talk with jay about
that i don't want to give too much away
right off the bat but before jay ellis
comes on in here we are going to go to
produce lucy who's here i'm not sure if
producing lucy is available on camera i
don't know if she's actually she told me
that she didn't get a chance to re-watch
man on fire so
i don't know if perducy lucy wanted to
come on camera and admit that she didn't
do her job lucy
what possible defense could you levy
that prevented you from watching man on
fire this week you know what i watched
vanilla sky for the first time
wow you had an evening a different tom
cruise movie yeah i have so many
thoughts on that but yeah i know i
didn't get to it i saw it in the i saw
it i think when it came out maybe
denzel that's all i'm gonna say he's the
best
i love him pretty much puts a period on
everything and the person we rely on to
put a period on what the critics were
saying at the time of its release man on
fire came out in 2004 we were so young
tim ryan our expert review curation
manager here at rotten tomatoes for our
segment called two minutes with time
[Music]
nobody's expecting vigilante thrillers
to be warm and fuzzy but critics were
mixed as to whether man on fire fire's
over-the-top action and frenetic style
was elevated by denzel washington's
assured performance or deflated by its
excessive length and sometimes brutal
violence man on fire is rotten at 38 on
the tomato meter with 169 reviews but it
does have an 89 audience score so what
did the critics have to say in a rotten
review destin thompson of the washington
post wrote that man on fire was a
predictable gruesome piece of business
that tries to ennoble one man vigilante
justice with the star power of denzel
washington
however in a fresh review todd mccarthy
of variety called it one of the more
absorbing and palatable entries in the
rather disreputable death wish style
self-appointed vigilante sub-genre the
rotten tomatoes critic's consensus reads
man on fire starts out well but goes
over the top in the violent second half
so that's man on fire let's kick it over
to jacqueline for some blazing hot takes
back to you wow tim well jaclyn's not
here am i not known for my blazing hot
takes on this show am i just am i the
vanilla to lucy scott here i feel like i
have some pretty bold steps forward or
backwards that i take on this show but
sharonda it seems like the critics were
just
split on
the violence of it is is that your read
on this it's just disrespectful it's
just pure disrespect lies lies we are
here for the violence
that's what made the movie and how how
dare you just focus on the violence when
they literally gave us a heartwarming
relationship between creasy and this
child played by the amazing dakota fanny
i can't even believe that this is what
was on their minds when they walked out
of the theater watching a man on fire
it's early in the show but you know
which way sharon is leaning you know
which way i'm lenny but now let's turn
it over to our interview with another
ellis i don't think we're related let's
ask him jay ellis is now joining us
[Music]
and as promised we are now welcoming our
very special guest from insecure
currently on its final season also has a
very exciting film coming up called
someone i is it someone i used to know
jay on amazon yeah
someone i used to know and somebody that
i probably should have known because we
share the same last name now last time i
checked you and i are not related is
that is that what we're going with jay
ellis on the show that that's what we're
going to go away for unless you are from
south carolina i'm from north carolina
my grandma lives in north carolina so
there's
my middle name is also ramon so
sometimes you know i think my grandma
might have been you know she might have
stepped out with the milkman i don't
know uh hopefully she doesn't listen to
this podcast but but yeah my grandma
actually lives in north carolina so who
knows maybe we're related we'll do the
23 and me because we got me from north
carolina we got south carolina jl is
representing and georgia that would be
atlanta representing sharonda williams
here today and we're talking about i
want to talk about insecurity i want to
talk about a lot of the fun stuff you
have coming up but the movie you picked
sharon and i were talking about it
before you got in here and man on fire
is one of those films directed by tony
scott starring denzel washington and
dakota fanning sharon and i are aghast
at its tomato meter school we can't
believe it's 89 on the audience score
which everybody hears man on fire and
it's like oh yeah it's definitely a
fresh movie it's fresh with the audience
with the critics 38
rotten on the tomato meter so jay ellis
you now have the floor is rotten
tomatoes wrong about man on fire a
hundred percent on this one you know
what i think it might have just been a
movie that was a little ahead of its
time in terms of like style and look
um you know it's it's it's hard to love
a character who's literally scorching
earth uh although he's doing it for the
right reason but you know i think it's
hard for for folks to sometimes come
around to that but this movie is just
everything i mean it's probably
my number two denzel performance ever um
yeah and it's it's probably
well it's not my number one tony scott
movie
we'll get to that later but it's
definitely my number two i have a
feeling i know what your number one tony
scott movie is uh sharonda you're such a
professional because i see you and i
both had to bite our tongues when we
were listening to two minutes with tim
and tim is going through all of the
reviews that came out at the time that
man on fire was released back in 2004
sharonda a lot of the critics had an
issue with the violence and now you have
an issue with the critics that had an
issue with the violence i mean first of
all the disrespect in these reviews
talking about violence which is like
that's what i was here for
listening to denzel go off from people
while he's torturing them that is the
sale of the entire movie so i just i was
just shocked i was just like with all
the violence we have now jay i think you
were right it probably was ahead of his
time
but it it just it really bothered my
spirit that the reason that it got so
many poor reviews was mainly due to the
violence i just i'm gonna pray for them
because i also
you know what maybe i'm gonna join you
in that prayer we're going we're gonna
do a circle because
what i also don't understand is the
title tells you what you're going to see
the title very clearly tells you this
man is about to do some damage so you
you knew what you were signing up for
yeah man on fire is a title where it's
not exactly going to be step brothers
like you know that there's going to be
something very intense happening in this
movie which ends up being the kidnapping
of dakota fanning and denzel washington
who better to hire to go rescue someone
than him but there's a lot of violence
there's a lot of stuff that happens
along the way jay when was the first
time you saw this movie i i don't want
to date you um i mean i don't really
want to date you in either sense but
it's nothing personal it's just how i
feel i don't want to age you i should
say when you talk about using this movie
were you old enough to see it in
theaters in 2004 i was in college when
this movie came out i just finished
college actually when this movie came
out so i'm i'm dating myself here but
yeah i actually uh me
and three of my college teammates uh
anthony hill rob johnson jack menashe we
all went to go see it in portland oregon
uh oh my gosh what is the name of that
mall oh i can see it i can see that it
has rose in it somewhere everything in
portland has throws something yeah oh
man
uh
it's gonna drive me crazy anyway we went
to go see it at the at the movie theater
in the mall at the lloyd center there we
go the lloyd center in uh in portland
and so you walk out of the movie and you
and your friends are talking about what
when you leave were you just blown right
away or like was it was it just this
amazing transcendental action experience
did you have to sit with it for a little
bit
no i think we immediately walked i think
you didn't want to see denzel go at the
end you didn't want to see crazy go at
the end i think that was like we wanted
him to pull through right so i think
that was something that we kept talking
about
um but also you know he did what he
needed to do and so there was also this
like amazing
full circle moment with that but yeah i
mean the action for sure i think
thinking about literally he there he did
not kill one person the same way
everyone or torture one person the same
way it was a different tactic for every
single person in the movie and it was
brilliant i mean and just the way it was
shot and
which of course at the time i didn't
know much about that but like
now have being able to look back and
think about that moment like it kept you
on the edge of your seat right all those
quick cuts all those like almost like
photo burned in kind of shots of the
city as you're traveling through like it
kept you on the edge of your seat and
waiting for something to happen every
single time and that was the thing that
impressed me too because this was one of
my netflix dvds sharonda this was one of
this was at that time kids if you don't
remember netflix before you just hit a
button and it and every movie ever
appears you had to ask them to send you
dvds and then you'd send them back and
then they'd send you more so this is one
of my dvds and i probably kept it for
like three weeks because i just could
not stop rewatching it it's so violent
like you said but it's also endlessly
rewatchable for whatever reason first
time sharonda williams came about man on
fire was when i mean i was a teenager
but i did see it in the theaters because
you know in my household if it's a
denzel movie coming out we going to the
movies to watch this church
there's no infants or butts like black
families black mamas oh i'm going to see
that denzel film so for me i liked it
but i will say that i do have some
issues after re-watching it recently it
is slightly problematic at some points
and they were very petty at the end when
they said thank you mexico city i was
like sir
you trashed mexico city this whole time
and then you gonna do thank you at the
end very petty but i'm gonna assume that
his heart was in the right place but it
does have some problematic moments in
the film i'm not gonna lie
that's fair and and he's done five
movies with tony scott and and he's done
he's done a few that are fresh but you
also have those well like deja vu was
like right on the cusp of being fresh
then this is the lowest rated movie on
the tomato meter that he did with tony
scott which is so shocking because it's
arguably the most popular one now that
we're looking back on it in 2021 so
let's get into some of the scenes that
we loved some of those maybe those
problematic elements that you're talking
about sharonda jay start with you what
is what's the scene when you think about
man on fire what's the scene that you
say that's why this movie the critics
got it wrong the audience got it right
i mean there's a couple of things i
think you know when you watch him
i got to say actually one of the first
scenes that pops my head is not a denzel
scene although uh
i'm gonna go through a bunch of them
when walken is sitting on the couch and
he's like with the detective and he's
like eaten
but he's also talking about how like you
know you can be an artist at anything
right artist at food and artists that
painting whatever it is and he goes art
is
our death is creasy's art and he's about
to paint his final masterpiece and like
to me like it literally sets up what's
about to happen for the next 45 minutes
of that movie like you clearly know that
this man is a what we've seen is just
him warming up like he's literally just
getting started but i think you know
the interrogation scene or the when he's
sitting in the car with the cop when
he's cutting his fingers off like
denzel's just so poised he's just so
chill about it it's just so easy about
reaching over and cutting this man's
fingers off while he's asking him
questions wait wait wait
give me one second
[Music]
okay my friend
is off to the next life for you
i guarantee you won't be
lonely then taking out his notebook and
just writing a few a few thoughts just
he doesn't want to forget these things
you know what i mean like it's just so
the performance is just so
nuanced and specific but also so
effortless at the same time i also love
there's this moment where he's sitting
outside of this club that he's about to
go into
and he's he's just casing the club and
even literally just watching him sit on
the fountain and like look at the club
and how he like looks over the top of
his glasses like there's you can see so
much is going through his mind like in
those moments
it's just it's all great i love all of
it
yeah shirana i don't think that denzel
ever needs to audition for any movie
again but let's just say he had to
audition for antoine fuco to be in the
equalizer you just play man on fire and
it's like this is the guy this is the
guy that can take care of any situation
and it's like moments like what jay said
one of my favorite moments is when he he
kidnaps one of the kingpins and he's got
him by his boxers and he's tied to the
car and i'm just gonna say it he
he puts a bomb in his ass he puts a bomb
in it now that is that's being created
to the next level you know that's not
the first time that denzel's character
has done something like that creasy
knows how to do this he he literally he
bought two of everything he bought two
of the plastic cartridge he bought two
of the bombs just so he could show the
guy what he what is currently up his
butt and i just i love how calm he is
because one of the quotes that denzel
has about playing this character john
creasy that i loved was that as the
pressure intensifies his heart rate goes
down which freaks everybody else out
because you think like a great athlete
who's just has ice water in their veins
during that crucial moment of the game
that's who john creasy is and it's
moments like that where one person one
unfortunate sob is is having the worst
day of their life and denzel just cool
as a cucumber i love stuff like that
sharonda your scene that says this is
why man on fire is either great or
something that you might have an issue
with you know what really stood out to
me i just looked at this movie like it
was a parenting movie and just let me
just just bear with me okay because
first
this girl was giving me like black
middle-aged daddy i don't care what you
kids want even in the random thing like
he was just like you got five minutes
like i don't know what to tell you like
i got somewhere to be but you need to go
ahead and tell me what you need to do i
was just like i feel like i was in a
parenting moment like that's how my
parent would talk to me like before you
get this ass whooping like i need you to
answer some questions before you go get
it no matter what and you don't get it
no matter what it's coming yeah like
that's that's what i was getting what
are you
going to do now what am i going to do
i'm going to leave i got to go
yeah we've got hey come on come on what
about me all right what about you we've
got 40 seconds
come on
last week please please
last wish
i wish
you had
more time and then also too like there's
a thing like where he's about to like
shoot someone and then the the man is
like hey like what about forgiveness or
what about letting god judge him he's
like baby i don't have that's not about
me i'm just here to make sure that he
makes his meeting with the lord to have
him deliver judgment it's just those
little like things that he had and how
he says it like i don't care like there
is no remorse that i have for anyone and
i think also too mark anthony i do want
to give him kudos because
this movie could have been called trash
parents
because when he talked to him and he
told him that he was an alcoholic and he
was just like don't tell my wife i said
sir
right then and there i was like the
daddy did it the daddy did it because i
don't know who was hiring an alcoholic
to watch their child but i just know
he's a trash parent at that moment i
also love the moment right after that
when they step into the house and the
wife asks him if he wants a drink and he
looks at mark anthony and says yeah like
a whiskey and a water a whiskey with a
water back like i love that he's like
yeah i'm gonna take this drink i know
you told me not to tell her but what i
got the job
what i give you it's also like because
you have denzel and he's a great lead in
here and he was he was asked about this
movie and and acting um against people
who are great actors like him he said
there's only two people in his entire
career i found this fascinating two
people in his entire career that he
actually found himself
that he had to stop watching them act
because he was just in the scene but he
was just enamored with what they're
doing one is gene hackman in crimson
tide the other one dakota fanning in
this film and he i love the way he he
described her performance because
somebody is referred to her as a child
actor and he's like she's not a child
actor she's an actor who happens to be a
child and in that scene at the end that
emotional climax where she gets released
and she's running on the bridge towards
him and they have that hug
all of it comes out on he's he's holding
it back
but she just lets everything out and
it's just such a beautiful moment
emotionally that's the thing about this
movie jay it's a great action movie it
like taken's a great action movie but it
doesn't get me emotionally worked up
like man on fire yeah this has heart in
a way that like
i talk about this with friends all the
time you know when we think about like
even from like the die hards through
so what is that like uh early 90s mid
90s something like that it was the first
88 so 88 you know and then you go
through like 2004 with something like
man on fire like there's this like
15-year 20-year period where like these
action movies had so much heart like you
you leaned into these characters and you
cared about these characters so much and
i think like that to your point like
although this is an amazing action movie
and although like you know if you if you
are an action junkie like i am like yes
you are excited to go watch him like
literally scorch the earth and i think
at one point he says he's gonna kill
everybody who was a part of it everybody
who
like might have been a part of it like
you know he he's gonna there's no end to
it but then you see those moments
you know there's this moment where he
looks down in his notebook where
dakota fanning's character wrote like i
love you creasy i love you crazy i love
you creasy or something like that and
like even just little moments like that
like they are they grab your heart you
know more than for example mark anthony
missing his daughter you know what i'm
saying like his character missing his
daughter and i think that's just so
powerful yeah there's something to it
sharonda where it's interesting jay goes
back to to die hard because that was
sort of the transition of we had these
huge muscle-bound heroes like
schwarzenegger saving his daughter in
commando and and it's nice he blows up
an entire country takes on a whole army
by himself but you never really feel
that emotional connection and maybe
that's because of the way
schwarzenegger's built it's like of
course nothing's gonna hurt this guy we
knew john mcclane could get hurt and
john creasy even though he's an expert
in all these different fields he he
still is immortal he he's still he's
amortal not immortal and we feel his
pain we feel his emotion did this movie
stir it up for you as well yeah i mean
first of all they gave us you know i
love sports movies like those are like
my movies that just make you feel good
on the inside and denzel gave us like a
whole sports movie while he was still
killing people
the whole women coaching things like
when we got to the meet and then she ran
and hugged i was like oh my they
literally could have took that picture
and put it as the cover and literally
pissed everybody off because
like you see that that moment and you
just like oh my goodness like i'm going
to take swimming classes i want to zeal
to be my swim coach like you just really
and especially to see how she was
getting on his nerves at the beginning
of the movie and like when she basically
pissed her off to where they ended up
like it just made you want to root for
creasy like i just it's like a
redemption story at the same time like
he's a man who has committed so many
sins and interacting with this little
girl is really helped him find peace
helped him find the resolve like you
know when he talks about to christopher
walken's character like you know all of
the things that we've done even though
they never told us in the movie that was
a problem i had but you just felt at
peace with his character and it was like
one of the times where you can actually
see a full circle moment happen with a
character arc even though he was killing
everyone the entire time yeah there's
there's like a redemptive quality about
it jay i don't know what it is about
certain movies where you have a
character we know that they have
horrific pasts where they've done a lot
of evil things but it's almost like if
he just gets through this thing okay or
at least if he gets dakota fanning back
in one piece it's like it's almost like
you're going to confession it's like all
of all of your past sins are washed away
if you just complete this one mission
yeah you know there's something i think
this character this crazy character too
like it's it's um
he's a purist you know what i mean and i
think that like in and that is both in
his job and taking care of dakota
fannie's character as well as his job
and going out and
executing anyone who might have been a
part of you know kidnapping her and i
think there is something that is very um
maybe not the right word but very
altruistic about it
in a really interesting way especially
the
the fact that he cares enough for this
girl
that he has not been working with that
long
but he cares for her enough to go
through to put himself in this kind of
danger and to go through a country where
he does he is he is an outsider and
cause all these problems there's
something about that journey that you're
like
yeah like you you putting it all on the
line man you risk it everything i'll
i'll throw it all over i'll throw i
don't care what you did wherever you
were before like none of that matters as
long as you keep doing what you're doing
for this reason and there's something
that is really uh beautiful about that
ooh
yeah go ahead that's a great setup yeah
like i was just like i don't think he's
still i don't think he's seeing heaven
like i don't think he gonna make it to
the pearly gates but after watching the
movie i was just like lord like i think
we can make an exception for chris right
i think he he did i'm not gonna say he
did the lord's work because you know
thou shall not kill
but i'm just saying
i think that we could definitely do a
petition to get creasy to the pearly
gates and at least get him at least get
him outside the gates even if he don't
get in at least he just camps out
outside forever i have a discussion like
let's just talk about a little bit but
the question is this
is he doing is john creacy doing this is
he going on this mission
more for
her more for dakota fanuc to rescue her
or is he doing it more for himself it
feels like he starts this thing out
because he has something to prove to
himself and then somewhere in the movie
none of that matters anymore and he just
needs to get her back yeah i think it's
a little bit of both
when we meet this guy there's clearly i
don't want to say selfishness but there
i mean you know it's like he's very
self-involved and there's some
selfishness and he has he clearly has a
drinking problem and he's dealing with
these demons i think you're right i
think he does feel like he needs to
cleanse himself and someone he needs to
do this for him he needs to know that he
can still do this he needs to
you know i think there's a thrill in it
that you know he enjoys it in a lot of
ways and then i think you're right like
somewhere in the middle of it and i
don't know if it's as he's kind of
putting the pieces together or you know
i think about that scene where he's at
the club and you have these kind of
flashes where the woman is telling the
story that like they threw her against
the wall and they did this and they put
her in the trunk and you know whether
those are denzel's kind of flashes and
he's thinking of those or whether
they're truly just you know obviously
flashbacks and we're seeing what
happened but
somewhere in there you do see it start
to turn and you do see him
almost care more about getting her back
than caring about whatever could
potentially happen to him i mean i think
for me i see
i think he was doing it for her because
i mean until the last what like 15 20
minutes of the movie he thinks she's
dead like he doesn't know that she's
alive like it's presumed she is dead and
he is just on this revenge mission to
make sure that everyone pays their
penance for having something to do with
her kidnapping and her death so
i think it was more so
i don't know if he was trying to write
the sins of his past but i think that he
was just at a point i mean at the
beginning of the movie he was already at
a point where he had nothing left to
give like there was nothing else for him
to possibly live for he's really just
going through the motions of life until
he meets his maker and i just think that
this little girl gave him a renewed
purpose and if there was one thing that
he was going to do because i think he
knew that he like this was going to lead
to his death he wasn't coming out alive
from any of this i think he wanted to
honor her memory until we realized that
she's actually alive jay earlier brought
up christopher walken's character and so
i just found this quote that christopher
walken's talking about playing this guy
paul
and i love the way he put it because i'm
not gonna do a walking impression
because i can't nail it but the quote
itself is that
uh he hoped that he upset people's
expectations in a way because i know i
carry a certain amount of villainous
baggage when it comes to these
characters this time it felt much more
interesting to be the good guy so jay
want to ask you this is an accomplished
actor is it more fun to play a bad guy
or a good guy oh i think a bad guy
it's not even a question a bad guy i
think you just get to lean into stuff
that hopefully you don't do it you know
day to day in like your regular life
your normal life um but i don't know
there's you know i think it's
speaking of there's this uh tony scott
quote about denzel and about how like he
brings a different version of himself
to every movie to at this point that
they had done right he he's brought a
different denzel
and i think like there there is
something that's to that like and when
you look at this guy versus like you
know alonzo from training day like
wildly different guys who are both out
there like doing what they are they are
very locked in on the thing that they're
gonna do
um but still wildly different so i think
you know getting to play a bad guy i
think is a lot of fun i think it's it's
it's um it's an opportunity to dive into
some stuff that you probably normally
wouldn't do and and maybe let some sides
of your you know personality and psyche
out that
that you kind of keep locked away or
that you want to explore whatever it may
be you know here's something i didn't
know though and i love both y'all's
reaction to this
75 of this film
was improvised
how does that
obviously they knew what the beats were
and where they wanted to go but sharonda
75 of this film
is improv how does that hit you i mean
it makes total sense like i said i felt
like i was watching my father if he was
like you know
like a killer but i mean from how denzel
was talking i was just like this is how
denzel talked to his kids like it just
felt like
it just felt like denzel like it didn't
feel as though that this is something
that somebody will be able to write this
type of dialogue
because it just felt like him and like
you know how you can watch movies and
you can tell like from the writing like
i can tell that they didn't write this
like with this actor in mind of actually
performing this role performing the
dialogue i just think just from his like
comebacks like what he's saying the
jokes that he has like
it truly feels like denzel totally like
made this up like this came from his
mind
you see why john david washington is
such a disciplined actor maybe after
watching man on fire that's the that
that's the household you grow up in you
know how to do things by the book jay 75
of this i imagine as an actor that's got
to be like going to candyland right yeah
i mean
it is an amazing amount of freedom and
and sounds like so much fun uh and i
think about all those moments again i
think you know those all these moments
where he's torturing folks and he's got
folks at gunpoint or bombs and they you
know rectums or cutting fingers off or
hanging from bridges like
there's gonna be improv on both sides is
gonna be improv because you're in a
situation like you're begging for your
life and you're pleading for your life
anything and everything you can say will
come out you know what i mean so you
don't get so you don't get killed and
then to your poise around i think like
you know denzel's just like he is
somebody's daddy he's like yo this is
like it's just gonna be what it's gonna
be you can sit here and cry or you want
to but you're gonna catch these bullets
so
you're going to tell me or you're not
going to tell me like either way you
know what i mean there's just this thing
to it where it's like i don't care
there's nothing you can tell me
at all that's going to change my mind
you're still going to get this woman
like this belt is still coming out and
like i think there is something to that
that like of course he was just like
letting it out he was just like saying
you know being him in a lot of ways and
and at least i think when you play a
character
like crazy who's probably been to the
the depths of darkness that that
character has gone to probably in
previous lives you know there probably
is some um
there's some lightness i guess in a way
i guess you find lightness
in very dark situations in order to get
through them at times and so i think
like why his joking through some of that
stuff i think is that it's like yeah
this is just life but it's gonna happen
like i i don't seem worse than this uh
we we've been hinting around it we've
been beating around the bush but you do
have an action role coming up soon and
it is in the tony scott lineage anyway
you're going to be in top gun maverick
and
jay you can't this movie can't get
delayed anymore all right i'm sorry to
put i i've been waiting for this movie
now for two years i remember seeing the
trailer when tom cruise went on stage at
comic con to debut it and i watched that
trailer like 35 times there's just
people especially people of a certain
age i'm 41 you see that trailer and it
just does stuff to you
all i've all i can tell anybody about
this film is that i've i've heard from
sources very close to the movie if you
only see one movie in the theater for
the rest of your life you have to make a
top gun maverick how excited are you to
finally have this movie come out
yeah i'm beyond excited man you know
it's been such a huge part of my life uh
three years of my life at this point um
and and it was
such an amazing experience to get to
work with tom uh and you know to to be
able to say like to your point that i'm
part of like a tony scott lineage right
and bruckheimer and don simpson and like
there's so many amazing folks han zimmer
like there's so many amazing folks who
are part of that original uh and who
paved the way for us to to come back and
do top gun maverick
you know my biggest thing
uh is i just want selfishly
every single person in the world who can
make it to a theater to go to a theater
to see the movie because it just
deserves that experience you know i
think we want it to be we want people to
feel safe
you know you want people to feel like
they can go out and enjoy it and feel
safe because it's a movie where like
you're going to lean in you're going to
get thrown back you're going to go left
you're going to go right like it has
these emotional ups and downs in it like
this beautiful emotional arc in it as
well as the action and i just think that
like i love watching a movie at home
like anybody else but this ain't the
movie that you watch at home this is not
it this is not the movie you watch at
home you go to the theaters for this
movie it is these these f-18s are
literally going to come flying off the
screen at you and you will have to lean
back and you won't get that same
sensation at home oh sharonda we might
have to go 40x for this one i mean he
just told me i was like you better hype
this up okay
you can go to the theater and you can
see jay in a movie like top gun maverick
which is i believe now this coming
summer next summer i guess is when
you're finally going to be able to to
see that in the big screen the way it
was intended if you're a fan of watching
jay on the small screen then you're
probably like sharonda and i and you are
a huge adorer of insecure which is now
in its final season we're about to have
the final episode
of insecure which is going to be such an
emotional moment for
i'm sure for you filming it but also
sharonda you and i were talking before
jay hopped on the show we've both been
fans of this for for pretty much since
its initial run i think i came on in
season two when molly the wonder dog's
mom introduced me to the show and ever
since it's been part of my sunday night
ritual when it's airing insecure and and
everything that it's done especially the
relationship between issa and lawrence
what what has this show done for you
sharonda
you know this shows actually prompted a
lot of
necessary conversations that people
don't talk about in regards to dating i
like that it gave people like this
vehicle to really experience what
relationships look like from a woman in
a man's point of view but also to just
being able to see people who look like
me like fall in love to see black love
on screen to see
black success you know especially like
with lawrence's character like the arc
that he went through of you know losing
himself and then really finding what
makes him happy i think that is some
things that we don't really talk about
that sometimes you have to kind of you
kind of have to hit rock bottom or you
might not know what you want to do but
you will find yourself and it's those
experiences through relationships
through friendships they really help you
and it's a series that just made you
feel like
it's okay for me to be where i am that
there's something better that's gonna
come up you know along the horizon and i
just think that it's just so impactful
to watch
a black cast you know covers so many
topics to start so many conversations
and to really just show us as human
on screen i just think that that's a
really big deal that's something that
needs to be celebrated and i think it's
a show that people are going to come
back to and reference reference for many
years to come so thank you thank you jay
no thank you
that uh that just melted my heart you
know it's weird to think about we've
just been in it like our heads are down
we just get up and go to work every day
and we love each other and we have fun
and you know season one we were like we
think this show is great we'll see what
people see when it comes out you know
because we were just so in a bubble
and obviously the response was amazing
but i think for us like every day we
still just got up and went to work and
and loved our characters again loved
each other loved our crew our crew our
crew i cannot give enough like love and
respect to our crew
to our writers um but it is wild
to be on the other end of this thing and
hear people talk about what this show
has meant to them
it is something that i don't know that
i'm fully ready for to be honest uh
probably because i don't want to be
dehydrated from all the crying
uh
but you know i i you know people throw
out like
other shows that are iconic to me and my
child whether that's martin whether
that's you know people people talk about
you know uh uh martin and and gina and
people talk about
whitley and and dwayne you know what i
mean and like there's just these moments
that
from other shows that are like seared in
my brain forever
and to think that like folks will think
about this show in that way especially
black folks in this country
will think about this show in that way
to me is like
it's crazy
it's really
emotionally yet like it did you have was
there a moment on on set when it when it
was your last scene and you rapped or or
is it maybe going to be once the final
episode air when does it hit jay ellis
like that the the finale of it all and
really gives you a chance to look back
on what y'all have accomplished
well mark as a ellis cousin you should
know that we dodge uh emotion whenever
we can vulnerability whenever we can so
i definitely made a joke out of my last
scene uh got up and like did a whole
speech and made a joke out of it because
i was not gonna let anybody see the
tears but i will say
uh we all the last week that we filmed
each one of us wrapped
a different night natasha wrapped i
wrapped yvonne wrapped uh issa wrapped
and we all went to each other and amanda
at the beginning of that week as well
and we all went to each other's uh rap
and
whether no matter what time it was
whether we were working or whether we
weren't working like yvonne wrapped at
three o'clock in the morning i showed up
at 1 30 and sat there we all we all came
in
same thing with isa who wrapped it like
six or seven in the morning
and
i was more emotional watching everyone
go through
their moment and their speech and their
kind of what this show is meant to them
and thanking everybody is that's kind of
when i was like
right
i didn't lose it lose it until
i don't want to give this away but we
there's something that that that we did
where uh
yeah i can't actually because that'll
fully give it away but right right yeah
we'll we'll say we only got like a
giveaway we only got another couple
weeks sharonda do you have any burning
fi any burning season five questions for
jay that he can answer in full i'm like
oh i got questions i have questions
look i mean one of the things that i do
want to talk to you about is really the
legacy of lawrence i mean we've watched
lawrence like
you know go from being hated at times to
you know
a whole campaign to bring lawrence back
to insecure i mean what is that
experience been like especially when we
thought that we wouldn't see lawrence
again and then seeing how so many people
were like no we actually need this
person what was that like for you i mean
it's wild like it's still
i mean
i don't know if i'll ever be able to put
it into words or to explain to folks how
much it means
that
they
i either identified related to
uh or were interested in whatever it is
this character that made
people
have the reactions that they have and
lean in the way they did and especially
you know i think about this guy lawrence
wasn't supposed to be after season one
like lawrence was supposed to die in the
finale of season one that was it like we
wasn't ever gonna see him again
and then fast forward you know five
seasons later
to your point like the amount of stuff
that we covered
in lawrence's journey
has i don't know if it's been done for
any male character period but it's sure
as hell hasn't been done for any black
male character
and
so many of my boys would hit me and
would just say thank you like i feel
like i'm being seen or i feel like i
just went through this with my girl or
we argued about that three months ago or
whatever it is and
to me it was just like
you know it's been an honor and like a
pleasure and such a privilege
to be able to play a character who who
really makes people feel like they've
been seen and feel like their story has
been told in some way and like they have
been recognized
and
and that is
you know it is it's everything it is it
is why i do this job like it is it is
why
i wanted to be an actor like literally
for this reason and
and here it is like with this character
and that's huge
we're this close to breaking him we're
this goes to breaking up sharonda he's
i really want to talk about i think it's
episode three
it was the episode with you
i was like let me say i call her
condolences let me say condola let me be
respectful but
the co-parenting discussion i i truly
think that it was one of the best
depictions of what co-parenting looks
like
outside of just for a couple that's not
together but even having people who were
married who deal with co-parenting
issues on how to take care of their
children i really want you to talk about
filming that episode but also to going
into when we see the growth
of that relationship later in this
season when you know you guys have this
conversation where you're just like i'm
happy that like we're in this place
you know what was that experience like
from filming episode three and going
into you know us seeing candola and
lawrence come out on the other side of
this
yeah i mean first and foremost i have to
thank my my co-star christina elmore
like i you know absolute brilliant
talent and genius and
she made every single day at work so
easy um and so fun and and
and we got to play and just find stuff
that you know i don't know if
i don't know if we would have found if
if it would have been anyone else so i'm
very very grateful for that um
you know
it's interesting because going into that
episode
really the last time we kind of see the
two of them together is when she tells
lawrence
that she's pregnant and that she can be
in the life or not in the life whatever
he wants right like she's happy with
whatever he wants to do and then fast
forward here we are
and you know on lawrence's side
uh he's trying and
he is flying back and forth and he is
tired and you know he probably didn't
realize the commitment of saying i'm
gonna be here every single weekend was
going to be as exhausting as it has
actually become to a certain point in
that episode and i think there's this
thing that's happening and i think this
has happened with lawrence
uh and i for me
this is the this is like the growth this
is where it turns but i feel like we
have watched lawrence for four and a
half seasons at that point basically
tried to push his way through things and
tried to make issa do something or his
job do something or any of the women
he's dated he's like i got this vision
this is my thing i got blinders on like
i'm just gonna go do it it has never
really thought about how other people
feel how they what they think you know
how their input should be you know
interspersed throughout his thoughts
whatever it is and i think that he's
doing the same thing with elijah and
what being with fatherhood and with
co-parenting he never asked you know
candola
what works for her what doesn't work for
her
you know he just is like pushing through
i'm gonna be a good dad this is how i'm
gonna do it this is my way and then you
have the kid and you do whatever you do
and then i pick them up but i want to
know everything and you need to tell me
everything when i'm not there and i
think that like this is that episode was
so
hard to shoot um for a lot of reasons um
it was very lonely
to shoot that episode i never felt so
lonely on step before and like i and i
think i hope anyway that it informed the
work in some way because so much of that
episode was lawrence by himself so there
was like a four day period five day
period maybe actually like a three or
four day period where i literally just
shot by myself
and it was and the crew was busy they
got jobs like they're trying to get the
show you know they trying to get a shot
set up like they can't entertain me
because i'm bored and i'm being by
myself so i literally was just sitting
by myself with nobody to talk to and you
can only look at your phone so many
times you can only scroll through
instagram so many times or look at your
phone so many times you know what i mean
and so i think like in a lot of ways
that really for me just really i i tried
to use that to inform where lawrence was
in being lonely in san francisco and
then this like
kind of crazy dream that he has that
like elijah potentially is gonna come up
there and like live with him maybe or
spend time with him as a baby you know
what i mean like not really thinking
about like what that means and he hasn't
done the job for more than 48 hours at a
time so he has no idea what that means
to do that for a full week right
um and then finally him and him and
candola have this blow up and and
because they're constantly butting heads
because they're they're doing it
different ways and not talking to each
other and
i'm not sure
the very end of the episode i'll just
say is like obviously you know the bumpy
flight which makes him think
i think in that moment he's like yo if
this plane would have gone down this is
not how i would have wanted
anyone to remember me the conversation i
had with condola is not how i would have
wanted to go out and not how i would
have wanted this kid not been in my
kid's life and so i think that for him
was enough to just be like yo i'm just
willing to try whatever
whatever it takes for us to be in a good
place
and then so you know to see them come
full circle and have that moment is is
beautiful and
so needed in the conversation because
it's so missed and so many people go
through that and sometimes it takes
months sometimes it takes years some
people don't get it
because they never get to have the
conversation and i think it's beautiful
that
isa
and prentice and our writers gave space
for that story
uh in in this season and in this show
and that's i mean look i i love lawrence
we're here to give lawrence's roses but
what's not mince words you put us on an
emotional roller coaster for the last
five seasons it's been up and down
there's times when i want to be exactly
like lawrence there's other times when
when i'm when i'm too much like lawrence
because i've been that chump that has to
pick somebody up from the airport and
then you get back home and then they
break up with you so i've i've lived
some of that life
it's been a pleasure having you here jay
i i know you're a busy guy you got a lot
to do uh he's jay ellis um again
insecure the season the c the series
finale is december 26 on hbo top gun
maverick and is next summer and of
course talking man on fire with him jay
it was a pleasure to have you on the
show we're both ellises i'm sure i'll
see you at the reunions but yeah until
then thank you so much for joining us
here on rotten tomatoes is wrong yeah
thanks for having me guys
[Music]
that was such a fun interview talking
really all things in the world of
entertainment with jay ellis i'll also
throw in because we were talking about
insecure i also there's another hbo show
called it surprises some people some of
the shows that i really get invested
into we're here is currently and i think
it's third season on hbo and it is just
it's just such a beacon of positivity in
a dark world it is so much fun if you
don't know what work here is don't don't
even i'm not even gonna describe to you
what it is just go put on work here get
through an episode you're not gonna
regret it you're gonna feel better about
yourself and about your life and you're
gonna want to hug every one of your
friends and make a bunch of phone calls
and text to people so check out we're
here um sharonda it it's i'd love to
have you back soon to talk about a movie
that maybe you feel passionately about
that somehow was wronged on the tomato
meter again everybody can find you at
pay or wait anything else uh coming up
that we can check you out on that you
wanted to mention before we say good
night here no just
tune in to my weekly insecure recaps
every sunday we're gonna we have two
more episodes left we're gonna get
through this together with the tissues
and the tears um but yeah just watch my
youtube channel for upcoming movie and
tv show reviews
god the just from the end of season four
to the beginning of season five where
lawrence and issa were and where they
left it off issa finally taking a big
step at the beginning of season five and
where we've gone from there it's a lot
to digest so i'm definitely gonna be
checking that out as well after i see
the season and the series finale on
december 26th you can email us anytime
here it's rt is wrong at
rottentomatoes.com we read emails on the
air a fair amount of times we love your
movie recommendations your thoughts on
the show what you want to see from us in
2022
for the great sharonda williams our
esteemed engineer brian perez producee
lucy and jay ellis i am mark ellis
possibly related and we'll see you next
week right here on rotten tomatoes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you